– St. Patrick’s Day feiert man in Irland,
und Halloween kommt aus den USA.
Wir müssen auch mal ’n paar
deutsche Volksfeste feiern.
– Du meinst Karneval?
Jeder, der in einem Kostüm kommt,
bekommt ein Getränk umsonst.
– Oder ein Weinfest.
Das könnten wir im Frühjahr machen.
Wir bieten eine Woche lang Weine aus
der Region an, die ganz jung sind.
– Wie wär’s mit einem Oktoberfest?
– Ja, dann kommst du aber in Lederhosen.
Oder du ziehst dir ’n schickes Dirndl an.
– Das ist dann wohl eher
ein Kostüm für Halloween …
– Ja.
– So, das ist erst mal
für euch beiden Hübschen.
– Danke.
– Und ... Sarah, Yara, Lisa, kommt rüber!
Nico! Nico!
Zehn Jahre „Das Marek“. Zum Wohl!
– Prost. Zum Wohl!
– Was denn?
– Bist du wahnsinnig?
– Sag mal, spinnst du?
– Du bist schwanger!
Du darfst nichts trinken!